dès l'année 2010 le département narino
été la première collectivité à ces à
s'engager dans cette démarche de sb à
nous avons voulu le faire alors que le
contexte à l'époque était en plein air
de crise économique pourrait justement
venir en aide aux petites et moyennes
entreprises en favorisant donc l'accès
de ces tpe vers les marchés de la
collectivité départementale et le but
c'était pour nous de leur fait de
l'activité aux meilleures conditions
possibles et surtout à travers une
démarche de simplification des
procédures administratives
le département a déjà engagé des
démarches de simplification des
procédures de commande publique cela
passe par la dématérialisation
l'amélioration des délais de paiement le
système des allotissements qui
permettent un meilleur accès à foix pour
les petites et moyennes entreprises à
nos marchés publics
et puis la pratique du juste prix parce
que les petites entreprises bueno
irrigue le territoire de la réunion
et comme le département est implanté sur
l'ensemble de l'île
il est important que quand nous
intervenons dans le sud que ce soit des
petites entreprises petites moyennes
entre pays du sud qui puisse répondre
dans l'ouest l'est c'est pareil et donc
je veux justement cette démocratisation
qui est effective depuis quelques temps
déjà
cette démocratisation de l'accès des
entreprises à la commande publique
départementale
[Musique]